well there has been a lot of talk about
new ideas today well
new ideas are fine
but they are also illegal for five years
I've held my instincts in check because
I wanted to be made manager
maybe it's time for me to just let that
thought go
it's kind of painful but it's also
freeing in a way
now it's all about my instincts
hey Dwight Stanley
one way or another you are going to come
with me to make this sale pass can you
just let me out of here before whatever
comes next don't worry it's just a bull
tranquilizer nothing to be alarmed about
it's just a man pointing a bull
tranquilizer at a co-worker Dwight you
do not learn do you for threat to be
credible
no you didn't I'm sick of you
thank you
it's all right Andy approved it man he's
really in twinkle town now is he gonna
be okay
I mean weren't those darts intended for
an animal like
two to three times larger than him okay
this dosage was meant for a very small
ball and Stanley's got way more body fat
than they do you give him three shots
this is going to be a very good year
very good
Jane is at home Jim is back
my protege Ryan is a corporate
good stuff
Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales
team I feel very blessed
[Music]
no you're not no you're not going
anywhere you're going to stay here until
we figure this out what you know what
this young man needs to learn that
that's not how you treat people
I don't care if it's pizza good business
is about respect and accountability and
follow-through you don't just make
promises and pull the rug out from under
somebody do you Dwight please escort
this young man into the conference room
right now get in the conversation I'm
not going in there you are yeah you are
and you will come out when you decide to
give me a discount on the pizza please
thank you
oh this is stupid yo you don't even know
what stupid is
it's about to get all stupid up in here
you find anything
we think it's a straightforward
kidnapping Stanley could you look up
accomplices why can't you guys do it
because we're looking up jail time
fine
I've seen this kid before he's one of
the kids that sneaks onto my farm and
steals my hemp yeah I know that guy he's
that farmer that goes really crappy weed
are you ready to give me my discount now
no
okay what have you been doing in here
this whole time what kind of business is
this we're a paper company the best
paper company in the whole wide world do
I knock it off
you'd better think about what you were
doing young man you better think about
what you're doing no
I'm an adult I don't have to think or do
anything you're a kid you're a little
snot-nosed Punk kid who thinks he's
better than everybody else because some
hot shot and you don't know anything
about sales
so stop being a disrespectful little
jerk okay sales yes sales you sell pizza
last time I checked that's called sales
you're such a loser what did you just
call him a loser what did you say a
loser okay
you just made this worse a whole lot
worse I can make him talk Michael I
don't know Michael Michael we are
accomplished
you need to let them go let go of a
little jerk boy
before he has learned his lesson yes you
know what Jim the world would be a
better place if people were held
accountable for their actions yes but
not by kidnapping kidnapping I'm not
kidnapping him I'm keeping him until I
get what I want as a hostage
I think you're overthinking it I think
you're under thinking if anyone out
there is listening I'm being held here
against my will
I'm a minor
thank you
last week I gave a fire safety talk
um and nobody paid any attention
it's my own fault for using PowerPoint
people learn in lots of different ways
but experience is the best teacher
today
smoking is going to save lives
here's the tip oh my gosh
is that the police yes well this is what
happened uh Ryan's big project was the
website
which wasn't doing so well so Ryan to
give the impression of sales recorded
them twice once his office sales and
wants his website sales which is what we
refer to the business as misleading the
shareholders another good term is fraud
the real crime I think
was the beard hey cream hey what are you
guys up to uh
buddy
I run a small fake ID company for my car
with a laminated machine that I swipe
from the share station
sorry
this moment my entire life
I mean I was in term manager once but
then I shot that gun what
yep yep yep
looking good
oh what a day what uh
Dwight are you carrying a gun The
holster was a gift from my great uncle
honk um I don't know I guess he's saying
that he's proud of me Dwight guns make
me really uncomfortable the gun is just
an accessory to the holster okay I can't
walk around wearing an empty holster why
do you need to wear the holster at all
why do you need to keep wearing those
booby shirts all the time thank you you
could put your cell phone in it instead
hello
you could put a banana in it why would I
put a banana in my holster in case you
weren't hungry now but you got hungry
later Dwight no gun okay don't make us
call Joe okay all right fine everyone
calm down someone get me a banana sorry
I freaked you guys out
it's so loud
can you tell us what happened
um I was walking to the building and
this man asked me for directions
and he was holding a map
and when I walked over he had it out
the mephillus you're a married woman the
guy was just hanging brain I mean what's
all the fuss
if that's flashing then lock me up
hey what let's see if any of these are
working hey hey White
Dwight I keep various Weaponry
strategically placed around the office
I saved Jim's life with a can of pepper
spray I had velcro under my desk
people say oh it's dangerous to keep
weapons in the home or the workplace
well I say it's better to be hurt by
someone you know accidentally
than by a stranger on purpose
so I need you to do some work on the
Saint Andrews account I need your urine
I need some filing done what kind of
filing that just forget it just the
urine that goes directly to the tester
just
I need your
like in a cup yes in a cup not animals
white but with purpose
have your business then I refuse okay
all right
I'm telling Alicia Keys concert
over the weekend
and I think I may have gotten high
by a girl with a lip ring
are you
I
need clean urine for the lady
my father's name was Dwight Schrute
my grandfather's name was Dwight Schrute
his father's name
twide shrewd
Amish
I love my father very much every morning
he'd wake up at dawn and make us
biscuits with gravy when I was little my
dad and I played a lot of games together
my dad cheated a lot but I never busted
him on it
I would have except I didn't know about
it he didn't tell me till years later
and I was shocked when I found out
what imitation is the most sincere form
of flattery so I thank you